why why would you make this what is the
point of they're the same they're just
different colors and one two and three
mhm and then some have got circles
around them some and there's a four over
there oh there's a four we a triangle
yeah four
triangle triangles and circles yeah not
not super obvious what it's for no it's
not popping into my head all right well
maybe somebody's figured it out by now
this these are
simultaneously for foursided three-sided
and two-sided diced at the same time so
at the same time you make one roll and
you get an answer on a four-sided die
and an answer on a three-sided die and
an answer on a two-sided die so again
first world problem but you've got you
have to carry fewer dice around you
don't have to carry a coin I mean who
who has money anyway these days so
anyway so okay so how do you read them
so the one in the middle or the one it
turns out in the middle is the answer
for your three-sided die so there's a
ring of four ones around
here and then you turn this way there's
a ring of four twos around
here and there's a ring of four threes
around here so well the shape here is
based on a romic do decahedron but it's
sort of rounded off at the at some of
the corners so we have these three rings
of numbers which give you the result for
the the D3 the three-sided time one two
or three 1 two or three and you know 12
total and then sped into three sets of
four when it lands on one of these
things you you get a circle and a
triangle on the top as well and the
circle and the triangle if you think
about the shape of this these are on the
sort of uh vertices with three sides
around them and those are arranged at
the vertices of a cube if that makes
sense so there's eight of them arranged
at the vertices of a cube that you can
sort of imagine being encased inside of
the shape and so whenever it
lands you get two of the vertices of the
cube
po
and we have circles on four of those
eight vertices of the cube to represent
the coin so that's the two-sided die and
triangle represent the four-sided die
because the standard you know shape of
four-sided die is the the tetrahedron so
that's the triangle and those are on the
other four corners of that that Cube
that's inside is every permutation or
combination equally likely excellent
question so or another way to phrase it
would be um are the are the dice rolls
independent right so you know well so
the answer is not quite so the
three-sided die is independent of either
the two and the four but the two and the
four are not independent so in fact you
can see that suppose you you you say
well what if I get a a four on my
four-sided die then what are the
possibilities for the two-sided die well
there's a one
there or you could get a one there or
you could get a two so if you're going
to get a four on your four-sided die
then you're more likely to get a one on
your two-sided die than you are to get a
two you can separate them out there
aren't enough Dimensions or something
but almost I can't imagine what sort of
gambling game would involve rolling the
D and taking all the different results
and mixing them up but but yeah that's
the one thing to be careful of okay nice
all right so that's that all right so
again what are these for and uh this is
not at all easy this is very hard I
would say to figure out what these are
for they go together obviously they're
not the same this is just a three-sided
die with 1 two and three whoops almost
Cliffhanger on the edge so that's a one
because it's the one you can see the one
is is sort of at the top and if it
landed this way that would be a three
and the way the shape is it can't land
on any of the ends CU it just it just
fls over there we go so that's just a
three-sided die this is an ordinary doic
aedon but the numbers are weird for
example there were two Sixers so again
why would we go to the the eite expense
of making this thing what is the point
is six the only number that's repeated
there's another repeated number four
repeated two
fours n no it's impossible so this is
um all right it's po so the idea with
these is you roll them
together you add up the numbers this is
a one and a four so we got five and when
you do that the prob ility the
distribution of the sum of those two
numbers is the same as if you roll two
ordinary sixed Dice and out of them
together this is a different way to roll
two D6 um that that's pointless of
course but I mean that's properly
pointless thank you how's a pure
mathematician it is it is my inali right
to do pointless things because they're
fun and because you can when you roll
two two D6 and you add them together How
likely is it to get each different
number so you just make a grid with six
slots here for the first ey and six
slots here and we can just fill it in
seven is the most common thing you can
get out of 2d6 and then it gets less and
less likely as you go the other
direction so the the different possible
outcomes are youve got a two one outcome
out of 36 because there are 6times six
possibilities that you get the three so
there's like a thing here this is 2 out
of 36 the four you're getting three out
of 36 and and so on the five is four out
of 36 6 is 5 out of 36 7 6 out of 36 so
you have a 1 and six chance 6 36 of
getting seven on on 2d6 and then it goes
back down again so all we have to do is
come up with some sets of numbers on the
dice which have the same numbers when
you do this there's a version of this um
for uh two cubicle dice which is not the
standard numbering but also does the
same thing and and these are called
cerman dice right so the numbering on
the the cerman dice are 1 2 2 3 3 4 and
1 3 4 5 6 and 8 so again not the
standard numbering obviously but now we
can just add it up another way to number
two ordinary cubicle 600 di let's just
do a spot check you're supposed to get
six sevens and 1 2 3 four five six so
you you they in the same they're not in
the same nice rows that they were in on
the other D well right because I mean
it's it's a bit Messier so um so let's
do this one what have you called this so
so we called these recast
2d6 so 2d6 being notation for take two
six dice add them together recast as I
don't know cast is sort of like you cast
your dice whatever I think you need some
marketing help yeah well so all right
and then we need 12 here all right so
this this is 1 two and three that's easy
so we know that there better be a one
somewhere on there right so there's a
one because we have to get two right and
the total has to be two and we've
definitely got a two this is very
dangerous I could scw this up well you
can kind of figure it out because so far
this is just doing this standard thing
here so I've got all of my fours already
yeah and I've got uh two of my fives and
I've got a six anyway so four there are
two fours there we go four four four
there are two fives five five and then
there are two sixes there is a seven and
there's an eight so there's an eight and
there's a nine yeah I think this isre
all right so let's do it so in Fast
Forward I'm sure three four three four
five
that's
six and
then six six s
z so we get the same thing this is maybe
a little prettier than this I don't know
you imagine like contour lines right
that the're that they're climbing up and
this is very sort of like you know flat
plane climbing up and these are all a
little bit more wonky somehow I know you
do this as a bit of a side business
right is anyone buying that has anyone
bought them uh don't know I could tell
you I mean who is the market I mean
there's certainly the marketing the
market of like you know sort of gamer
types probably this is not terribly
popular with the gamer types but there's
also you know math neres and some of
them like this with I know a few math
nerds yeah all right all right all
right so um these are four-sided dice
right you can see well this is a one and
that's a four and that's a three but the
shape is kind of
interesting so what is the shape
for so maybe you've
seen things that look like
this these um not dice but uh these were
I think produced by Ma gear so M thing
shapes of constant width they are shapes
of constant width so if you have a book
you put on there then you get a nice
yeah yeah got to get a nice book okay so
all right a book and then you
go okay sh lovely same thing with these
so um so there is a bit of a story here
and uh where these came from and the
shape and all that sort of stuff so the
book is always staying at the same
height above the table yes yes so if you
did this with ball bearings or spheres
then you would expect that yeah it just
sort of smoothly rolls around and it's
the same thing with with these shapes
even though these are not spheres it
still stays con constant height and and
stable and it does so for these things
as
well um so I first heard about these
like constant width foret of dice on the
Grand Illusions Channel they had some of
these dice that somebody had 3D printed
this guy Sean Bentley had 3D printed
these shapes and so we said oh that's a
great idea why don't we Mass roduce
these things rather than 3D prining so
you know we talked to him and and he
gave us a blessing and and so on and so
forth now there's interesting things
going on with the shapes so if you look
at the math gear tetrahedra the Rulo
tetrahedra and these constant with
things not all the edges are the same as
each other maybe you can see like this
shape is kind of sharp whereas this one
is
rounded and that you know works for the
constant uh width property but it's not
good for the fairness of the die right
the it's got to have all the Symmetry in
the the edges that are different you
know in principle it's going to be
easier to roll over this Edge than it
would be to roll over a sharp edge so
these are not going to work so this guy
sha came up with a constant width shape
that has all the edges being the same so
you know they're all rounded in the same
way way rather am some of them sharp and
some of them rounder and so this you
know this works and this was the design
he went with and we looked at this and
thought well hold on a second there's
another problem that we need to solve
when you're making a dice for Mass
reduce injection molding part of the
process the mold comes together in
multiple parts and the plastic kind of
squeezes out there's like little bits of
rough stuff and they put it in like a
tumbler to smooth out all the you know
the imperfections and make your nice you
know shiny dice problem is that the
tumbling process is going to do
different things to that sharp corner at
the top than it is to other places on
the die the shape would be changed
different amounts in different places in
the tumbling process so we couldn't use
it um I should I should mention by the
way these are prototypes these are not
this is this is sneak preview nobody
nobody has ever seen these before
hopefully soon these will be out these
the prototypes so what are the what are
the things we need we need the the shape
to be symmetric it needs this you know
all the faces all the sides the shape is
well it doesn't have faces anymore it's
sort of
rounded but it needs to have that that
same tetrahedral symmetry it can just be
a sphere and the the the edges needed
and the corners needed to be rounded off
and so we ased around a little bit and
eventually somebody put us onto this
paper or by Brandon guil foil and
William Wilhelm klingenberg sorry if I'm
messing up their name which did exactly
what we needed so on C2 smooth surfaces
of constant width so c0 just means
continuous yeah if it wasn't c0 then
like there'd be jumps or like it will be
broken apart C1 means that the tangent
directions match up it doesn't look
sharp but it's not as smooth as it could
be and C2 is saying that if you imagine
like uh the the graph of x Cube has got
that nice sort of smooth thing down
there that's the kind of smoothness that
you're getting so it's not completely
completely smooth but it's visually um
you know quite smooth and and the Hope
was that with the tumbling process
because it's got this extra smoothness
it wouldn't get tumbled down so much and
um yeah somewhere in here in this paper
eventually there's a nice picture of
exactly what we needed oh this is
looking good that's looking familiar
right there's all kinds of fancy stuff
in here and then yeah this is this is
like right this is what we need spend a
little bit of time trying to read their
paper and figured out and there was like
why don't I just email them and oh they
were like oh yeah oh please you know
have have a go at the and then so they
gave us the code and then that and then
here they are and uh hopefully available
soon thanks for watching this video be
sure to check out the video description
for links to more of our videos about
dice more videos with Henry and also
links to the dice you've seen today you
can buy them you can check them out I'll
include all the information you could
want again that's in the video
description there's a drill as well with
uh and it's got it uses that triangle